本当に今日なのかなちょっと恐々なのかわかりませんとっつなんでしょ
なんかツイッター見るとしか今日だった気がするんですよね有無
まあムって打つと最近たくさん出ますよね
対処代謝だったりちょっとこのことについてちょっとだけ肌と思いますまあなぜ境遇6
に触れますかといいますと
もう何度ですね六月二十一日僕の後輩の誕生日でもあるんですけども
うーむの創立記念見出しです歌おめでとうございます
南寧7ねーもう7年も有無で着て立っているということで本当おめでとうございますれ
ば段編むいつもお世話になっておりますはいということですねちょっとあんまりねああ
あのあんまり口を開かなかったんですけども園最近結構話題になっているわけですよ
うーのクリエイターさんがめっちゃ当たったりしたとかなんかやめたとかそういう話を
よく聞くんでなんかそういうネガティブな
まだ今を何か僕たちクリエイターさんヒカキンさんとか僕と彼を所属している
クリエイターさんとか
残ってる人たち誰も触れない方がいいのかなと思うんですけど僕はこれまあ通常もあの
本当に徒然と思ったことを喋ったいと思っております別にね
いうことは悪いことじゃないと思うんではいというわけでですねなんかほんとすごい
話題になってますね最近フールのクリエイターさんユーチューバーさんが卓球
3やめるという話で頑張りね他のユーチューバー興味ないんでるっちゃ気いうとどうで
もいいんですけどもやっぱ中そのニュースとかね話題になると耳に入ってくるんだよね
ですけ
エメリンさん意味銀チャンネルとか蝦仁チャンネルさんとカート
[音楽]
誰だ選べたのだったって誰誰えっちゃんも良いたのいいほんとやめてんじゃん
外れてしまっ釣った
特に何も思わんですね僕はどうなんでしょう
なんで辞めるかは本当にそれぞれだと思うんですよ入っているメリットを感じる感じね
ほんと人それぞれとと思うしなんかなんでしょ別に止めたところで僕は
グーンっていう感じでしかないですね僕が無津呂なんかお話ししたこともある方もい
ますし動画を一緒に撮ったこともある方も音止めちゃったりしてるんでやーなんか普通
にはやめちゃったんだっていう感じですねあの
3ね色んな理由があってやめてるんでしょっこが何か別にブームが悪いかとか
greater さんが悪いかとかよくわかんないです多分あってなかったんだと思い
ます
先生者に僕うん所属しても6年くらい経つのかなご労苦年くらいルームにずっといるん
ですけども僕は全然そんな不自由を感じたことないです
わかんないですね額角的クリエイターさんの中で上の方にいるからかもしれないです
そっかほんとわかんないんですけどあと僕売るしか知らないからかもしれないんです
けどもあの僕はめちゃくちゃ感謝してます本当にただあの僕もずっとねそんないいです
いいで最高ですありがとうございますどーもどーも吸ってピック北してるわけじゃなく
て結構僕は神に思ったことを言ってるんですよ
なんとか本当は言いたくないです
けど仲良しが一番いいんですけどやっぱり一緒に仕事をしていく事務所なんで本を持っ
たことをちゃんと言った上で話を聞いてくれてるんですよ
でマネージャーさんとか結構関わってるんです実はいろいろあったりしてちゃんとそれ
言った結果変えてもらったりいろいろやっぱしてお互い分かり合いながら歩んで56年
経ってるんで
僕は特に
やめようとは思ってませんどうなんですかねあの
おりませぬ梅のことをよくわかんないんでクリエイターさんも多いして社員さん多いし
なんか大変だなーとか思って高報酬増加から東京高みの見物してるんですけど私がもう
満を持して言いますいい事務所だと僕は思っています僕はですけどね
は金相撲結果が飛ばないといけない世界ですから
youtube も数字とかチャンネル登録者数とか何かそういうファンとかそういう
のはないと成り立たない状態なんでもちろんそういうのがないとそれ相応のそれ相応の
見返りというかそれそんなサポートを受けられるのはもう当たり前です実力主義の世界
なんでここけっこうこいつよ youtube の世界なんで僕はひょっとしたらなん
か人気とかなくてすごい下っ端で再生成も全然取れないようなに宇宙ばだったら沸騰し
たら不満を言って
かもしれないしそこはも実力の世界なんでなんとも言えないんですけど僕はとりあえず
心から
楓が大好きでいつも親身になって考えてくれるマネージャーさんとかも大好きで海に
入る前も何がちゃんとお話しとかしてくれたり最近もたまになんですけども展示的に話
を聞いてくれるか皆さんが大好きで盲腸月あの使っても良いくらい僕はずっと海に入る
と
言わせてください何でしょうもう10人に心から言いたいっていう気持ちもあるんです
けど綺麗すぎりっぽいいいところですねあの知ってる人もいるんですけど僕何回か大大
大炎上
1回か大大大現像は大外大吟醸1階ですけどポツポツと玉に定期的に炎上することが
あってなんかそれでも見てずに過ごし親身になって頑張る炎上あれば何かいいとして
ないところで大きさの現状とかまってそういうなか僕結構
うってなってる時にすごいすん日に話を聞いてくれたりこうすればいいですよとか適切
なアドバイスを下さったりもうその大会
憎悪した時とかに眠く見放さずにずっとついてきてくれてたおかげで1階居間
つの底に落ちたわけじゃないですかその空打ち這い上がって今も youtube られ
ているのは僕本当に産むのお陰だと思ってるんで
ん
俺はこの傲慢
いやつらかった時は
+よあったしすごい迷惑かけたんで本当に俺は申し訳ないと思ってるし俺誰に一番迷惑
かけなくないかというとたぶん家族と部の人たちの周りの中に友達なんですよそこには
欠ける上る一番嫌なんで今までたくさん迷惑かけたんですけれどもそれでも僕を庇って
くれて日本もこうやってサポートしてくれて俺にはもう帰しようにも返せないほどの
大きな
女あるんですよねだからいろんな人に食べに売れるんじゃね最近 web を辞める人
を受けないとか言われるんですけど僕はそれを聞いたところであーなんか雨が悪いこと
したんだなったも思わないんですよ
わかんない海にいるからオスんですけどあの僕にとってはまったく問題ありません
さっきも言ったんですけどもうこれは感謝しかないんで地の果てまでついてきますよ
日まで
3今のところは何があってもついていこうかなと思っております
でもたくさんの人のバーンてみると良い大丈夫なん事務所とか言われるかも知れない
ですけど少なくとも俺の話は俺は少なくともずっと5月4て話をしたかったですこの7
周年という記念にねはいというわけでちょっと他の国ダーさんがどう思ってるか全く
知らないんですけども包み隠さず僕の思っていることを話させていただくとスト
いう感じですもちろん僕が気に食わない事だってあにま違う人間なんだから完璧なサ
ポートっても存在しないんですよどっかでだけし合いながらお互いをこう高め合って
しなっていけないからじゃないとやって来ないもんだと思うんですねマネジメントって
仕事はうーむ
はあのクリエイターが第一ってずっと何か言ってくれてるんで僕は本当にその言葉が
助かってるというか
めちゃくちゃ診断して今後も海にさせていただきたいと思いますわかんないひょっとし
たら俺がめちゃくちゃ数字落ちて人気がなくなっちゃうとまた考えが変わるかもしれ
ない俺が生活するために何か別の手段を取らなきゃいけないってことがあるかもしれ
ないんですけども現場は一生ついていく
させていただきますこういうこと本当にルームの社長のかまださんとかに直接言えば
いいですけどこっ恥ずかしいんであえて動画にして公開告白させております
いつも本当にありがとうございますよ皆さんこれからも程よくがんばるぞ
dee
[音楽]
うぉっは